Go pull up Gaming for Hope. Go pull up
some body cam footage. Go pull up the
boring useless that your audience loves
all the slop and just pour the slop out.
Okay, put the slop in the bag, little
bro. Just be the whole man. If you're
going to be a
be the whole and ignore the situation. I
just want you to have enough of a spine
to shut your stupid mouth.
I
I caught a clip from Chud here. Hold on.
>> [music]
>> He sent me a clip from Chud and I do
want to talk about it cuz it's I just
don't get why
I don't get what Chud's doing when he
even talks about this stuff to be honest
with you. Like it just seems very very
very goofy to me.
So I'm basically just thinking about his
comments on the reporting stuff.
And I just think it's very very very
silly to be honest with you.
I totally I I'm totally fine if Chud
wants to distance. I understand that.
Like not wanting to participate. I think
it's like bad. I think you should
probably when you see like something
that's quite bad happening to other
people, something that basically affects
your line of work. Like if you're a if
you're like a blacksmith and you notice
like the mobs going and
or like like some group of other
blacksmiths are going like intimidating
other people and they're giving them
part of their profits, right? If you
never stand up for that, you're just
just go give them your profits right
away, right?
You know what I you know what I mean?
Like it's if you don't care if you're
not going to do anything about it, then
I guess just like accept that reality
and then move on.
Or you know, in this case for Chud, like
just go start doing your other content.
But I don't understand why he keeps
reviewing stuff from this sphere and
from this like situation and then
commenting and going, "But I don't
really want to be a part of it or I
don't really want to talk about it."
Actually, what I really want to talk
about is
like how weird it is for these people to
call for reports at all.
Let's let's take a look. That's what he
was annoyed with me.
>> [snorts]
>> He's talking about me. me.
He's talking about women.
But, um, I don't know, man. I just I
just think there are some things he's
done. Um, Chud is obsessed with optics.
No, he's not. No, he's not. Optics is a
way to just like fudge and muddy the
waters and never take an actual position
on things. He's not like obsessed with
optics. He just wants to make his money,
which is fine, but then don't talk [__]
about the people who are trying to like
actually take a position. Is all I would
say, right?
Like if you're going to be and like
calling him spineless, it's
Well, I actually hadn't called him
spineless yet. He is spineless. But,
calling him spineless is not really an
indictment of him. Like if I had kids
and I was like, you know, getting a
house, I would probably be spineless,
too.
Right? He's got like a lot of things
going on that make it so he would be
invested.
Right?
And so, I get it, but I just don't get
the consistent hand-wringing.
Like it's quite frustrating, the
consistent hand-wringing over like my
actions or Acandros's actions. Like this
stuff over and over and over again.
Why are you focusing on that? To me,
it's very clear what you're trying to
do. So, I'm get I'm actually helping
Chud here, okay? So, I'm going to talk a
lot of [__] about Chud.
And I'm going to help him, cuz what he
wants is distance from me and like me
saying I reported Destiny, right? I'm
just just going to help him and point
out that he's like obviously just
self-interested and trying to pretend
there's some actual analysis there, but
there isn't. He's like, "I'm not sure if
it's coping. I'm not sure if it's real."
Right? But, he's trying to pretend
there's some analysis there. There's no
analysis going on. He's just
transparently scared, which is fine.
Just say you're scared.
Right? Don't come and say like, "Oh,
it's it's actually totally wrong for you
to do this." No, it's not.
No, it's not.
Like actually just either either give
some real analysis
or [__] off. Take Take the Pisco pill,
right? And just leave the space. Don't
talk about this [__] at all, because you
don't want to be involved. Don't take
potshots at the people you know like
you.
Hoping that it gets you further out of
the situation you can kind of just fire
potshots off. Very cowardly, very weird
behavior, in my opinion. Okay?
Right? But from there we get into this
Dickers and and Aiden debate. And he
starts like hand-wringing again. Dude,
actually just go and watch something
else. Go pull up Gaming for Hope. Go
pull up some body cam footage. Go pull
up the boring, useless [__] that your
audience loves. All the slop and just
pour the slop out. Okay? Put the slop in
the bag, little bro. Don't try to do
analysis on this [__] if you're too
scared to comment.
>> done. Sure.
They're just trying to isolate Jstark
because he reported Destiny for the
endless barrage of doxing. Yeah, I don't
know. I just think
you know, participating in any sort of
reporting or talking about reporting. If
you think someone's broken the rules,
you have to report their channel.
And like leave it at that. I think
you're you know, open yourself
Uh so there's a just total disconnect
from actual like deeper analysis there.
Right?
So he he says that he thinks there's
just some doxing that happened. He
doesn't know the context of this. And he
he's basically trying to argue that no
matter the context, it wouldn't matter.
And obviously if I put him in the same
context, I'm pretty confident Chud would
say, "Oh, like no, I would have to do
something more."
But we'll keep watching.
>> trying to get other people to do it, you
know, like just go and do it yourself.
Right? I mean, you know,
if someone is genuinely doing something
that you think is wrong, there's nothing
wrong with using the reporting tools
yourself.
But when you talk about it, it's just
you know, I mean, I don't know. I've not
seen the evidence, but
what's the line between talking about it
and mass reporting?
And I just got I've got a phone
Oh, I literally had like a guide for how
to do it. It's a very complex report to
do. I had like a guide for how to do it,
to report him.
Well, I think I think technically
somebody else had it, but
I can totally defend that and I will
defend that.
>> well, I wouldn't like, you know, I
wouldn't like cut someone off from mass
reporting necessarily. I don't think
that's like a hardline for me. But I
certainly would be less, you know,
amicable with them. Let's put it that
way. I wouldn't want to like knock about
with them because it's like
like, why are you doing that? It's like
it's like a bad look on you, if if you
like. Do you know what I mean by that? I
I don't see why. It's not a bad look on
you at all.
It's not a bad look on you at all, so
long as you can explain it and want to
look into it. You are too scared because
your platforms are gone. So, you're
saying things instead of saying, "I'm
too scared to go further into this
because I don't want to get my channel
with."
Which is the answer.
You just do some like surface level
analysis. This kind of looks bad. This
kind of looks bad. That's all we're
going to hear as I go through this. This
kind of looks bad. It creates a risk for
my channel, right? This kind of looks
bad. It creates a risk for my channel.
Does he know the deeper context on any
of this? Has he tried to look into it?
Or is he just like, "Oh, I'm just going
to do some surface level like
analysis, look at the way Dan frames
things, and then go, 'Oh, this is like
really bad. I I totally disavow this.'"
It's understandable. I That's what I
said at the beginning. It's totally
understandable why he's scared. I have
no problem with him scared. I have no
problem with him
at all
being scared. What I have a problem with
is him going and basically helping the
people who are doing the actual bad
behavior by perpetuating this narrative
that there was something wrong with
doing the reports.
That's all I'm asking is instead of just
be the whole [__] man. If you're going
to be a [__] be the whole [__] and
ignore the situation.
That's all. That's all I'm asking for.
Right? If you're going to prostrate
yourself like this, which I understand.
Listen,
I understand that what it looks like is
we're like the the truck is Sorry, we're
the like the guy with the briefcase in
Tiananmen Square or something, right?
Like you are totally
I get that you don't want to go stand
next to that guy. That makes total sense
to me.
But, just say, "Hey, I don't want to be
anywhere near that. I don't want to do
that."
That's fine.
But, don't say like the principle of
standing there is wrong. Principally you
should never stand there. Principally
that it can never happen ever.
Cuz that's wrong.
At worst at worst the only criticism you
could have here is that I basically
explained to people how to do this
report in a space with other creators
who could be put at risk. That is it.
That is it. That's all. And also don't
forget I'm still being like very calm
with this.
This is all to help Chud. Cuz now Chud
can go and react to this and and I can
have attacked him over it and we could
be totally disconnected, right?
So all of the comments about his
spinelessness and
That's that's all helping him.
Helping him disconnect. And again, I
should reiterate he's not spineless
because he's worried about his channel.
That's not spineless. He's got other
other things going on with his life that
he needs to make sure are taken care of,
right?
The spineless thing is like helping the
other group by making it seem like I'm
the person who did something wrong or
Nek Andros is the person who did
something wrong because you're scared of
them.
That's all.
You're like you're basically enabling
them in their behavior.
It's like I don't want to you know
that's not my
That's not me. I don't want to do that
[__]
And I just think J Stov and Nek Andros
I just think they're like terrible at
dealing with this [__]
Like they get involved in these like
high pressure dynamics and fights.
And they're just [__] at dealing with it
and they're terrible at
Uh again, I had not really been covering
Destiny that much like almost at all. I
think I had been doing like the
conservative civil war was like the the
GOP civil war. I was doing like all
politics content content. I was not
covering Destiny at all.
Right? And then he started threatening
people. Started threatening to dox
people, right? And then he started
doxing people.
And then once he made it clear that not
only so I should have put this. I have
the most important things on my side
here.
Okay? And that's the facts. The facts
are on my side. Destiny
admitted, okay, he admitted he did this
and he stated like actual malice in
doing it. I am doing this, I'm going to
go after these people. I if he he gave
warnings about doxxing and then he
followed through on the doxxing like on
the doxxing attempts that he said he was
going to, right? Actual malice.
Actually has acknowledged that he has
doxxed people multiple times. So, he's
done it intentionally, repeatedly.
And these are objective and self-evident
violations. They're not things that are
subjective and that's a big deal because
if you're trying to call for mass
reports on any subjective standard, that
creates like a a deception on your part,
right?
But we're not doing it on a subjective
standard, we're doing it on an objective
like piece of evidence, right? Destiny
has himself said it happened. Oh, wasn't
DGG? Yeah, they were. They were. They
were. But
so leave alone the fact that Destiny has
called to mass report me before this,
right? Leave alone that cuz I'm not
going to say an eye for eye is
appropriate. But I will say that it is
absolutely appropriate to take this
course of action in this situation. To
get other people to help do this complex
report on his channel because he is
using his channel to continue to exert
pressure
and basically spread this message and
call for more doxx and call for more
people to be harassed.
Right? That like that is Listen, that's
um those are smaller things. But once he
got to the point where he stated that he
had the actual intent to quit my
community, to make people leave by
doxxing people in the community,
absolutely I was within my rights to do
this. To create a guide on how to report
him and give like links to all of the
specific like PII leaks he had done.
Right? So,
again, we have basically everything you
need to prove something happened.
And then he basically is going to argue
that mass reporting is wrong, right? Why
is mass reporting wrong?
I guess I can think of two reasons mass
reporting is wrong, okay? One is you're
reporting somebody on a subjective
standard and you're trying to in-
indicate to the people who review those
reports that it's so past the subjective
standard that they don't really think
much about whether or not they want to
take action, right? Or you're working on
some subje- subjective standard like a
slur or like some hate speech thing and
as additional reports come in you create
you increase the chance that some random
like support staff will flag the
behavior,
right?
But this is not either of those
situations, okay? It's not either of
those situations. So I don't think that
anybody can really argue that the mass
reporting is bad outside of that it
could have negative consequences for the
people around me, but guess what?
There are already like maximal
consequences for the people around me.
Now not not in terms of reporting and
again, Dickers ref- basically said this
is he shouldn't do it. Chudat said it's
he shouldn't do it. Aiden never even saw
this [__] to begin with. He might have
some principal agreement with me, but he
never about this at all. So like the
other creators around me don't about
this at all. They're not looking to
report. They don't want to anything to
do with it. So again,
that's fine.
Okay, that's fine. I'm not mad at these
people for not wanting anything to do
anything to do with it. I'm mad or I'm
annoyed at the idea that you would go
and instead of instead of just ignoring
this, you will go and cover it and do it
in a way that helps the people who are
engaging in the like catastrophic
behavior towards the commentary space.
That's what the outcome of your actions
is. When you go live and you know that
Dan is a threat to you, that Destiny is
a threat to you and that Qman, me, all
these people are not and then you spend
all of your time hand-wringing about our
behavior and nothing on them, the
outcome of your action is you help them.
All I'm asking for you to do is to not
help them.
I'm dealing with it.
Do you know what I mean?
It's like and and it's like I don't want
to be corny thing, but like why why
would [clears throat] I want that near
me? Why do I want someone near me
>> [snorts]
>> that can't deal with these things very
well?
Does that make sense? It's like you're a
[__] idiot. You're a [__] idiot
and you're terrible at dealing with this
[__]
I've got other [__] to worry about
rather than someone doing stupid [__]
And you know, I don't want that
splashing onto me. That's got nothing to
do with me. That's not my [__]
lookout, you know? Yeah.
I would I would wonder why he called
what
I would wonder why he called Nicholas
Ybarra at all for his bad coverage.
What was the point of that? Why Why
would he take a stand there?
That had huge negatives for you.
Right? Why did you take a stand there?
You cuz what you just said, oh I just
don't want that [__] around me. Oh, I
don't want like any bad Well, if
somebody's like
if somebody's
basically chilling speech all over the
internet
why in the world would you say, oh well,
I don't want anyone around me. I never
want to talk about it.
Right?
Outside of or at least why would you say
that and then go on your stream and
basically advocate for other people to
say that? Why would you like demoralize
the side that's trying to stand up for
some principle or some
higher ideal?
I don't get it. Um
They don't volunteer. Well, sure, yeah.
I mean, obviously, you know, I defended
Lakandula and [snorts] Shmee on you know
on like a a basis of their credibility.
Which, you know, in hindsight maybe I'd
have handled it differently if I'd known
more information, but what can you do?
What can you do? You can't rewind time,
unfortunately.
You're saying J Soc you're I'm saying
he's saying that J Soc
in in in correct me if I'm wrong Dan,
but that this Dan said we're innocent.
Well, let me get to that part. I don't
give a [__] about this. Let me to that
part.
>> Uh J Soc organized mass reporting of
other people.
>> Step by step. And I understand that
Destiny and J Soc are in a holy war, but
you guys you have standards. You don't
do that [__]
No, we we have standards against doxing,
Dan. We have standards against standards
against doxing about like intentionally
[__] with other people's communities,
right?
>> [clears throat]
>> So, again, what happened here is Destiny
stated that he was going to people if
they didn't stop covering him.
Then he started trying to dox those
people.
Then eventually gets to the point where
he starts trying to dox people in those
communities who are commenting on him.
Okay? And he revels in and celebrates
the fact that people are leaving that
that community because they've been
targeted by him. Okay?
You can say oh well, you know, you can
say to yourself, well, I shouldn't be
involved. But what you can't say is it
is wrong to organize those the people in
that community when again there's
admitted stated malice, there's
intentional repeat offenses, and it's an
objective self-evident violation. It's
not subjective in any way. You cannot
say it's wrong to report that or even to
advocate for others to report that.
Because it's not.
It is like the objectively correct thing
to do. You just don't like that it's
going to possibly [__] up your money.
Now, the sad thing here or perhaps the
saddest thing here is Chud was not in
the Discord. Chud was not connected to
this, and he got reported by people.
Right? I've been I was live on Twitch
for 12 hours yesterday covering Destiny.
I didn't get reported like I fine.
So, I don't know. Like he I understand
he feels like in danger or threatened,
but that is the whole point is you
basically stop covering the other side
of this. You stop talking about the
other side of this.
That's why they're doing it to you.
That's why they're they're they are
forcing you to play by rules that are
not the rules they play by.
If you want to just let them warp the
playing field, then yeah, go somewhere
else, man. Just just don't comment.
You're different. Well,
yeah. Okay. Well, he did that. I just I
I didn't actually review this before I
went live or I reviewed a little bit of
it, but um most of my commentary was
going to be on the other thing, but I
did want to start here cuz it it feels
important to start with this.
>> You guys watched it. You let it go by.
So, let me ask you, why should that not
be done to you? In like a Destiny
actions?
Okay, but you're you're hanging
>> Okay, dude.
>> [laughter]
>> The problem is it doesn't matter to
these people. They don't care whether or
not you've not done something bad from
their perspective. They see it as an eye
for an eye. And this
They don't even see as an eye for an
eye. He just said something completely
afactual, completely
They don't see it as an eye for an eye.
They've never seen it as an eye for an
eye.
They didn't come back at me or Kweiman
or anybody doing this and go, "Oh, we're
going to cover you guys. And we're going
to like make jokes about you guys." They
started trying to dox people. They
threatened to dox people. It's not an
eye for an eye at all. They're going
insane with their escalations. And
they're trying to chill any criticism of
Destiny to abet crimes. That's what
they're trying to do, Chud. And all I'm
asking for you to do is find the spine
not to stand with us and and say that's
wrong, not to do what I would say is the
right thing. I just want you to have
enough of a spine to shut your stupid
mouth. That's all I want. Just have
enough of a spine to go crawl off into
the corner to prostrate yourself. Don't
come prostrate yourself in order to trip
us.
That's all.
That's all I'm asking for, man.
>> This is why, even if you think you're
justified,
God, I'm it's it's just awful We keep
going. It's awful to do it with people
that are psychotic and we just want to
go eye for an eye at you. Like, why why
get into it and talk about it? You just
open yourself
This is just the gilded poo position.
Well, actually they doxed me and they
they swatted me, but I would never
report somebody. I would never do that.
Are you out of your mind?
I understand By the way, I understand
not talking about it. I understand,
right?
I understand not talking about it. I
understand wanting to walk away. I'm
totally fine with that. You This is not
your fight. You don't have to stand here
and fight. This is not existential for
you. I understand having a
self-interest.
It's just this. It's just this whole
thing of like, "Well, actually they're
going an eye for an eye." No, they're
not. Never been an eye for an eye.
They're always doing extreme
escalations.
A chase dog, that's gay. He's just doing
By the way, that's what it's going to
be. When Chud says, "Oh, it just looks
Know that in his heart he understands he
is gilded poo. That's why he's got the
hat and the beard. He's just gilded poo
going, "This is gay and cringe. This is
gay and cringe." You don't have an
argument. You are essentially lying not
really to anyone else, just yourself.
That's all.
Self up.
For like exactly the same to be done to
you.
Do you see what I mean? And this is the
thing is like
you know, people doing this thing with
the contros where they're like, "Yeah,
man, go him down. Go him down." What are
you Yeah, you're down. You're getting
him. You're getting him. You're getting
him. And it's like this guy has just had
a year-long war with Twitch, right?
What Why you Why you, you know, putting
your head in the lion's mouth?
Okay.
So, what if they What if they went to
that war? By the way, W Twitch.
What if Twitch just decided to
deplatform Hasan cuz they didn't like
that they were losing advertisers?
What if that was the way it worked?
Dan almost has enough power to get Hasan
deplatformed.
Dan is openly wanting to do it. What did
Hasan do to Dan? Nothing. They don't
need a reason to go after you. And by
the way, Chud, I hope you understand
this because maybe you're maybe you're
lying to yourself about this, too. Or
maybe I'll help you get away. But, if I
didn't do this stream, if I don't go
live and call you a coward, call you a
for doing this,
you did enough. You've done enough.
You're already an enemy. You don't get
to walk away.
They're not going to stop reporting you.
They're not going to stop any of this.
Are you serious?
By the way, you immediately came out and
knelt right after that conversation. You
knelt and were like, "Oh, I can't
believe I defended a contros. I'm such a
Why did I do that? Why did I [screaming]
do that?" And then, what, a day later
you go, "Oh, I'm I'm going to ban
Shimmu. I had no idea. I had no idea
THAT HE'D DONE ANY of these things. I'm
just Yeah, please, Dan, solve it,
please."
Why did you even walk away from Nick?
Why did you say anything bad about Nick?
What was your criticism of Nick? Like, I
get it. I get I totally get it, okay? I
get not wanting to start a fight with
them, but just the whole thing where you
have to come back and like hit the
people who you're friends with makes no
sense to me whatsoever. Especially when
you don't really have any grounds to
make these criticisms on when you've not
about yourself with the facts. Do you
see what I mean? It's like just don't
you know, you don't want the smoke. You
don't want the smoke, do you? It's not
worth it. Like, what are you gaining
from that interaction? What are you
gaining from that fight?
He did nothing to Twitch, no.
But but do you want, you know,
a guy that's that relentless on your
case? Probably not, no. For what
benefit? For what upside?
Do you see what I mean? Like
I
Basically, the benefit of hoping that if
something similar happened to you, you'd
have a couple principal people who'd
stand shoulder to shoulder and say that
was wrong.
Do you know what I mean? That if you
were the person being targeted, that if
you were the person who is the target of
some psycho with a big platform, that
you'd have other people who come along
and go, "Hey, that's [__] up. Hey,
that's wrong." I don't like that because
that's where we're hurtling towards
really fast. We Have you not been paying
attention to the entire H3 saga where
they are using lawsuits under false
pretenses to go after people. Just slap
suits
explicitly.
This is the same tactic but with doxxing
and real life harassment instead, okay?
Or the threat of real life harassment.
That's what it is. You understand that
your entire way of life, your whole
thing where you critique things, where
you you're a critic on the internet. You
are providing commentary. That's what is
at risk. Your way of life is at risk.
And I understand you can just take a
knee and go and do your little show and
basically probably run out the clock and
never have a problem.
But you you shouldn't handicap or
hamstring the people who do want to take
some kind of stand on this, man.
That's all I'm asking. Just don't
hamstring.
Right?
Just walk off.
>> What what benefit are you getting from
that? What praise from Twitch?
Sounds like chilling effect. I don't
think that's chilling effect
necessarily.
It's abs- dude.
I don't think that's chilling effect
necessarily.
How
old are you right now? I don't think
that's chilling effect necessarily. Um
What?
Are you
the most man on planet Earth? Hold on.
I didn't realize I was covering Chud's
face. I shouldn't have been covering it.
The most man on planet Earth. Oh, I
don't know if there's like a chilling
effect here, guys.
What the [__] are you talking about,
man?
>> I'm talking about Nikondros doing these
autism threads.
Nikondros was doing giga autism threads
and saying all this crazy [__] about
Dan. And yes, Dan was saying crazy [__]
back. It's not about the chilling
effect. It's like, what are you getting
from that? What's the upside? What's the
benefit from that?
Well, sure. You can call it a chilling
effect. Okay, fine. Fine. Call it a
chilling effect if you want. Yes, fine.
Yeah, you are the most dude. Dude, his
entire chat is like, yeah, why doesn't
he want to criticize Dan anymore? Cuz he
thinks he's [clears throat] going to get
[__] idiot.
I don't know if like Dan's threats to
[__] people are really creating a
chilling effect. Nikondros went silent.
And again, I don't blame him for going
silent. That's fine. At the At the very
least, at bare minimum, Nikondros wasn't
so much of a
to go and start criticizing anybody else
who was criticizing Dan. By the way, I'm
basically taking a knee on criticizing
Dan. I'm I'm mocking Chud for
hamstringing the people who were doing
it, who were criticizing Dan or Destiny.
But I'm basically taking a knee on
criticizing Dan cuz I'm trying not to
get anything else [__] up, okay? But
like, I could just say that. I don't
have to pretend that I'm standing on
some kind of principle. Well, actually,
there's like a, you know, what what what
do I gain? No, I'm scared that if I keep
like if I keep criticizing Dan,
basically a bunch of other allegations
about me are going to arise that are
have totally meritless, totally made up,
right? So, I will take the knee. But at
least I can say it.
I don't think Come on. Does You really
think there's a chilling effect?
Brother, you just You just said this guy
is a schitzo and he's in a holy war with
Twitch.
You know he's been doxxing people. You
know these people around him have been
doxxing people.
You talk about that.
>> well I take the hours of chilling
effect. Yes, I agree. Yes.
But to me it's like you wouldn't go to
war with a kiwi farmer, would you? A
kiwi farmer is not participating in the
same marketplace you are.
A kiwi farmer is not a massive it
doesn't have a massive platform and has
not done like the same things worthy of
that that level of criticism, right?
What the [__] are you talking about? Why
are you pretending that the whole point
of like of going against these people is
they have the resources to harm a lot of
people and the entire platform's speech,
right? The entirety of YouTube speech.
That's why people are going after them.
That's why people are criticizing them.
What how What is this false dichotomy,
man? This false equivalence.
Dude, this is he's doing like every bad
argumentation thing to get away from
like saying I'm just a [__] and I want
to run. You're a [__] you want to run.
That's fine. That's fine. I don't even
say it with hate. I get it. I Listen, if
I had
if I had kids, I would do the same
thing. If I had people I needed to take
care of that way, I would do the same
thing. Would you have a convo with chat
about this? Yes.
>> And that's my perspective on this. It's
like, you know, you wouldn't go to war
with a kiwi farms person and that's a
chilling effect. But then the upside is
you're not going to end Dude, but I you
know, I don't want to get into the
details of I don't want to expose
Does a kiwi farms person have like tens
or hundreds of Yeah, you do want to stop
talking about it cuz this is a totally
false equivalence. God.
Who's in I need to stop my follow
certain accounts on Twitter that are
close to kiwi farms, right?
And as a result of all of this that's
happening there is some crazy stuff that
is happening, okay? That's all I'll say
on it. But like
you know, people just get posted. Like
you don't want to be anywhere near this
dude. And this is the thing is
That's all you need to dis That's all
you need to say. I don't want to be near
it.
That's all you need to say. I don't want
to be near it at all.
It's so easy, man.
I don't want to be near this.
That's all the commentary we need.
>> Precisely. I thought this all seems like
a mess like that. Do you see what I
mean?
And so I made the decision to obviously
not really get into it. And and yes, you
know, I did decide to have the
conversation.
And I'll, you know, take take
responsibility for deciding to
participate in some way. But then, you
know, I take a step into it, two of my
channels get you know, a measure against
them. My Discord gets taken down for 12
hours. And that's the least of it. While
other people are getting like full docx
man. It's
Hey. Okay.
You This is again
You should actually delineate between
what's happening. Like you're just
talking about this in a sloppy way.
You're getting like a You're mixing
things. That sounds like people are
getting docxed for speaking up against
Dan.
Right? That at least in the most recent
thing, I I've not seen that happen.
Right? Not that it wouldn't or couldn't.
Crazy how that
And the thing is it's like it's not even
it's not even necessarily people that
are in these different two different
sides. It's like, you know, KF people
are sniffing about and they want to
slice of the action as well.
I need people within these two sides. I
don't even know what this means.
I've no idea what this means.
>> I mean?
So I just think you're kind of putting a
target on your back if you are
participating too much in this. What is
this?
And like scream
We'll get near the end of this week.
lecting
So Logic was not in the server. While
you guys [__] in DGG and whatnot.
Hate the guy, whatever. He wasn't in
there. He was living his principles.
Kweiman wasn't there. But when I looked
through I didn't see any crazy [__] from
him. That's not to say his community is
not involved, but he wasn't in there. He
wasn't doing any crazy [__] And in
fact, I saw him pushing back.
>> Dude, it's just so crazy to me that like
this needs to be said. Like yeah, this
[__] is literally nothing to do with me.
And somehow well there was this effort
to kind of implicate me and and drag me
into it, which I participated
I mean, the effort was just to destroy
you because everybody around Destiny
hates you and they're going to keep
hating you.
Do you think Do you think Stardust is
going to hate you any less? Do you think
Not So Aerodate is going to hate you any
less? Do you think these people like you
now, Chud? You think they're going to
let this go? You think they're never
going to come out the next time you get
in any kind of fight whatsoever and
bring up every single one of these same
attacks to go after you with?
What do you think's going to happen?
But don't don't worry about it. Don't
think too far in the future. It's fine.
>> I'm going to be wrong.
Um the only the only possible thing you
could say is that there's people from my
Discord that participate in that
Discord.
Yeah, people can join different Discord
servers.
Yeah, again, SP, we understand why Chud
is a [__] I just want him to say he's
That's why he's a [__] I don't want
him to do this hand-wringing all the
time. So, he's not doing it now. Now,
he's like pretty much fine. He wants it
to be clear for people that he's not
involved, right? And I'm doing him a
favor. I'm saying you're a spineless
for a good reason,
but you're spineless. So, he can be mad
about it. He can be angry at me. He can
disagree with me,
right? And I distance him from it. I'm
doing him a favor. People can join
different Discord That's not in my
control. And I will ban people if they
doxx, obviously.
You know, that is something I'm willing
to do cuz I don't want to be near that
[__]
But like
if people are being mean, harsh
[__]
engaging in behavior that I disagree
with,
you know, it's like that's not really my
concern. What's What's that How is that
my Like, could you imagine if the shoe
was on the other foot and I was going to
Destiny and I was going Destiny, there's
this server, some of your members are in
it, you're not in it, and you probably
don't know about what's in there, but
you need to answer for that and you need
to tell them you need to you know,
you're involved in this.
It's like
it would be completely unreasonable to
expect that from Destiny. But yet, it's
expected of me Yeah. Because what the
[__] did I do?
I mean, Destiny's basically expecting
that of a bunch of other people now.
You know, it's like the expectation of
other people.
>> the standard. They don't have standards.
You already
This is the weird thing is he's acting
like it's an eye for an eye or that
there's a standard happening here.
There's no standard applied. You didn't
have anything to do with it, right? And
you still got reported. You still got
with You still are a part of it. You're
getting attacked by a bunch of people
who are adjacent, right?
Okay. Anyway, we're going to go to the
next segment, which is this one right
here, okay? This is the This is the
better one. This is the more involved
one.
All right? You know, there's a lot of
kind of like flying around by him, but
>> He's talking about me here.
>> I don't know, man. I just I just think
there are some things he's done which is
just stupid. Like what?
He was saying that after Destiny started
doxxing his community, he was telling
people in Discord server to report Yeah.
The thing is even even if you're just
strike while you're dead. Strike while
your enemy is being Yes, exactly. That's
That's good logic to go by.
In fact, I'm going to ask Destiny if he
needs any help with this gay manifesto
that he's doing.
That's a joke. I got to talk about that.
Obviously.
>> any help with J Talk segment? I can you
know, maybe maybe I can give you some
pointers. But um
The mass reporting thing, dude. I just
No, he's It's not even that he's
perceived to be a part of it. It's
perceived It will never not be perceived
that he's close to Kweiman. And as long
as he's close to Kweiman, he'll be a
part of it, right?
But he wants to He wants to pretend that
he's going to get distanced. He's not
distanced.
Right? Unless he wants to totally
disavow the like somebody he's
incredibly close to, right? I don't care
how justified you think you are.
I don't care how justified
Why? Why Why would it not matter? What?
Like basically, you have to have
You have to have the gilded poo standard
here. So, Chud, if I were to put you in
this situation, you would never call for
these reports. You never ask other
people for help with these reports,
right?
If someone was putting your kids at
risk, someone was doxxing you, your new
home, right? And then doxxing people in
your community, doxxing mods, uh mods,
other streamers, um like fans of yours,
right? Trying to chill and then
explicitly like laughing at you when
people leave because they don't want to
be doxxed. You would You would say,
"Well, it's actually still wrong to call
for anything to say anything about that.
It's It's totally wrong to suggest that
other people might want to report that."
What? How?
How could you have that standard? How
could you possibly
>> think
>> are. Do not advocate for mass reporting
even for your worst enemy.
Obviously, if you think someone has
broken the rules and you want to use a
platform's reporting tools,
that's your prerogative.
Okay?
That's up to you.
I was aware of his like totally
spineless Nicantros like disavow a
stream or whatever. Oh my god, I can't
believe Nicantros did that. Where he
totally like knelt and tried to get out
from under the the boot of DGG. I was
aware of that and back then my thinking
was, okay,
I am not going to say anything cuz then
we'd have like a fight and it's like a
fight would just not be optimal. Like no
more brother wars were we're literally
not doing that right now. But now it's
like this is like day three or four of
him doing this same cocked hand ringing
like a
Just shut the [__] up.
You don't have a point. You don't avail
yourself of the facts. You are a
Which again, I would be too if I had
kids, okay? But just stop. Stop
pretending. Stop pretending this is
like, oh, this is a really important
thing. You sound like gilded poo. He's
about to go I guarantee you he's about
to say the same thing. Well, this just
looks kind of weird. Doesn't this look
like weird guys? Doesn't it look like
like optically it would look really bad
to do this? Doesn't it look like
optically bad? I feel like it's coming
on. I can feel the Nicholas DiOrio
the the I Nicholas DiOrio, I don't have
an argument but I don't want I don't
want to take any responsibility right
now. So here's how I'm going to explain
this moment. Oh, it's just kind of like
optically bad? But even if you feel like
you're justified,
calling of it, you know, you you are you
are calling for the weaponization of
reporting systems in order
Wrong.
Wrong. It's only weaponization
means that you are doing something that
is outside that you are trying to fool
them somehow.
That only you can only really call it
weaponization when it is a subjective
standard. If you're trying to report for
hate speech, if you're trying to report
for some slur, right?
If there's some subjective standard
required on the person who gets the
report, right? They have to do some
subjective evaluation of it. Then mass
reporting is wrong because you're trying
to increase the likelihood that that
goes through.
This is an objective standard. This
person is objectively doxing and using
an adjacent platform to YouTube to do
it.
This is admitted
admitted malice on Destiny's part trying
to harm my community saying he will dox
people, making the threats, and then
following through, okay? It's an
objective self-evident standard. Like it
has happened.
It is out there. He published the
information, right?
And it's intentional repeat offenses and
the stated intent to do it further,
right? So he's trying to Imagine
somebody's trying to destroy your
community. Somebody's trying to destroy
your way of making a living.
Right? Is it wrong to report? They say
life ruination. That's what DGGers say.
You're trying to ruin his life. Is
Destiny not trying to ruin my life by
targeting my community directly and then
laughing as people leave? Hello?
By the way, targeting my community with
something outside of the accepted arena
with doxing
and creating the possibility, the risk
of real-life harm. That's what he's
doing. That's how he's trying to chill
speech. He's not making a really great
argument.
He's just threatening people. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So the weaponization thing I
think is totally cocked and wrong.
with the trying to get And by the way,
again, I do actually need to restate
this. The reason he's talking about
weaponization or trying to pretend that
he has some principle here without
looking into it, right? Is because he
doesn't want to just say, "I'm scared of
these people. I don't want anything to
do with it."
That's all he should be saying. That
should be his entire commentary on this
stuff because instead he's scared to
look into it. He's scared to get
involved. He's scared to care. So he's
just going to go, "Well, that looks
really weird." and walk away.
That's why he should just say, "I'm
scared." and walk away to begin with.
get an outcome that you want rather than
just reporting some of these things
happened wrong. And I don't care who it
[__] is. I don't give a [__] if it's
Destiny. I don't think it was Techtone.
I don't care what
Why the [__] would you compare Destiny
and Techtone? Are you a
You a [__]
knuckle-dragging
What is the comparison? Why is he doing
these false equivalencies? Well, yeah,
even Techtone's like really bad, but I
want to report him.
What has Techtone done that's anywhere
near these three facts? He's admitted
stated malice. He's stated his malice.
He said, "I'm going to dox these
people." And then he's followed through
and tried to publish information on
those people.
Done it multiple times and says he will
continue to do it.
And that these are on an objective
standard, that the information is
published and it is verifiable. And what
is it? Um
that it can be verified by a third
party. It's independently verifiable.
What has Techtone done that rises to
that standard that he uses his platform
to enable?
There is nothing.
There is nothing like that. It's not
close. It's not even a little bit close,
right? He's not using it to try to take
down critics.
That's not what's happening, right? And
again, this is all to chill speech and
harm critics.
Intentionally.
Why do you keep going? You know? No,
advocating for mass reporting.
Because you know, you're you're you're
trying to weaponize those tools then.
You Those tools are designed that if you
see a problem, you think it's an issue,
you file the report.
>> Right? That's how it's supposed to be
used. Where does it say that?
Wouldn't it be like through the platform
then? Wouldn't it be like you can't even
like link to it? The act of calling
other people to report it, you are
trying to weaponize those systems. And
the other thing, too, is that's that's
the
How much time has he spent looking into
why the reports were filed? Does he have
an idea of why the reports were filed?
Cuz he might think it was just doxing,
right? He might think it was just, "Oh,
this guy hates Destiny." I have said
multiple times, this did not happen
until we had the additional element of
him targeting the community,
right? And stating that he's doing so to
to chill the community, to destroy the
community.
That There was no reports before that.
Okay?
Why are we pretending that like I he
just didn't look into anything or he's
intentionally
obfuscating? I don't know which.
I assume it's
cuz if it's if it's intentional, that's
that's false.
>> actual criticism of it.
>> I'll keep going. But also, it looks
dreadful. Like also optically it's a Oh
my god.
Also, it just looks really bad.
Hey guys, Nick Fuentes here and I just
want to tell you that because I have no
argument, I'm going to say this looks
really bad. Guys, this looks so bad.
Doesn't it look so bad, guys?
Oh my god.
Yeah, totally Chad. It Your actions were
responded to proximately. Yeah, 100%.
You had to do something bad for these
people or to these people for them to do
something back to you. Yeah, for sure.
Bro, just let the schizos win. Just
appease them. Let the schizos win.
Absolutely. Yeah, totally totally
totally.
Then listen, Chad Chad sitting there
it's like, "Dude, this uh
this guy had a butter knife. That's a
weapon. I didn't want to take the risk,
so I bent over and let him me in the
ass." Okay, that's fine.
Listen, I don't mind you running away.
Just don't help the guy, right? Don't
try to hold other people down while he
other people, man. That's it.
That's all. Without thinking about it.
And then you you like try to stand here
and pretend that it's not just that
you're scared. You do this your thing. I
I've seen this like point being made of
like, "Well, could it work in the other
direction?" Well, no, they've not done
anything wrong.
Irrelevant. Doesn't matter. It will
still be used to justify mass reporting
against you. And whilst you can't really
stop
Okay. But you should say that that's
wrong. You should analyze the facts.
That is the entire purpose of giving
commentary. Analyze the facts as they're
given to you and say who the good and
bad actors are.
And but you can't do that because you're
scared of the actual bad actors. So
you're cucking your own analysis to
support them instead of just shutting
the [__] up.
>> Stop that, right? You can't You can't
stop that from happening. Like my [__]
is definitely been reported.
I think you are creating a bigger issue
for yourself
because undoubtedly if you are calling
for it, there will be, you know, a more
like
passionate desire to [__] your [__] up.
Do you know what I mean? Okay. Well, I
didn't think, you know, seeing people in
my community making people leave, saying
you will dox anybody participating or
discussing your lawsuit, which has been
said, that that definitely like wasn't
enough, right?
That they have way more things they
could do. They have like so much more
they could do to me. Yeah, definitely.
Which by the way, I tried to avoid this
part. I tried to avoid like when I said
I would I could do it
with Kick. I never did that and I never
called for it like at all. I never made
any concerted effort to call for it
publicly.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I explicitly avoided that because I
didn't want anybody else to get run over
by this. Yeah. And it's like, dude, you
know what would have been better? Would
have been a whole bunch of creators who
saw what Destiny was doing and them
standing with a spine. But I couldn't
get that. We couldn't get a bunch of
people going, "Hey, we're not going to
collab with this guy or talk about this
guy. We're going to just say this guy.
We're actually just going to do negative
coverage of him until he stops doing
this
till he presents some evidence for why
he's been doxxing people. I couldn't
have that. I couldn't get people to
stand with a spine there. And now I
can't even get people to stand with a
spine on, yeah, it was okay to like call
for people to report him. I can't even
get people to not say it was bad to call
to report him. It's just I Dude, it's I
it's wild. It's wild. Like obviously I
can't predict the future,
but, you know, I mean, I hopefully,
fingers crossed, I mean, obviously I'm
still going to play it careful.
But like
I think any sort of mass reporting
against my stuff, touch wood, is kind of
at least died down a bit. But could you
imagine if there were logs of me
advocating for like the reporting, mass
reporting of Destiny? Like it would
probably still be happening now.
Like it probably still be being used
against me now.
Have you considered getting some
self-control, some impulse control, not
constantly violating the TOS on every
platform you inhabit?
Have you thought about that?
Streamed 12 hours yesterday and that's
today.
Right? I've been streaming on Twitch
every single stream. I don't know, I
just I feel like probably you could just
get some self-control, too.
I understand that you walked the line,
but you constantly like flagrantly jump
over the line, too.
And I like the comedy, but you're not
even attempting to really follow the
rules of the platform, so I don't know
what to tell you, man.
Whatever.
Obviously, I hope Chud I hope Chud's
channels do well. I really hope they
don't get like anything um like I I do
cuz I I do like his content as much as I
think this is a totally position. I do
like his content. I would love his
channels to do well.
Okay?
Hey, man.
So, you're watching me go through your
own back if you advocate for that, even
if you feel like you're justified in
doing so.
Yeah, again. Just keep saying Just keep
disconnecting the context and
justification from the thing so that you
can criticize the thing without looking
into the people you're actually scared
of.
This is This is as
directly as I can say it, right? If he
looks into the context, he would have to
discuss the context and the actions of
the people he's scared of, right?
So, he's just going to call out the
response to that context, to that
justification. He's just going to call
that out and avoid the entire context.
And for me, personally, I just think
that particularly is like egregious,
cowardly behavior. Personally, that's
that's how I feel about it. It's
egregious, cowardly behavior. It's not
an accurate criticism. It's not accurate
analysis, and it is analysis that is
explicitly driven by fear.
And I would not have a single criticism
if all Chud said was, "I'm actually
really scared of these people and the
mass reporting that they're engaging
in." Maybe if leaves that part out cuz
he doesn't want to upset anybody. You
don't want to trigger the schizos. So,
maybe you just say, "I'm really scared
to cover this
and I'm not going to comment." Right?
Then you don't spend all of your time
focusing on the possible wrongdoing of
the people close to you who are actually
being harassed, who are actually
concerned for their safety, right?
Then you could just avoid the whole
problem.
But instead, we've had like three
streams now of this hand-wringing
I don't know. This this is like
hand-wringing spineless
and I'm I'm just kind of sick of it. I
would like to stop.
If if it could just stop, that'd be
fantastic.
Or
do a balanced analysis.
Look into some of this stuff.
Stop being a
unless you want to be the whole
So, two options.
Do an actual analysis, figure out the
facts, stop being a
or be the
and walk off.
Don't do this
Oh, it just looks awfully bad. I
couldn't possibly look into what's
really happening here or or give my
actual opinion.
Stop doing that.
And walk on.
My god, man.